I'm not for abortion oh shut up [__]
I'm not for it but I'm not against it
easy it all depends on who I get
pregnant
I don't care I'm tell right now I don't
care what your religious beliefs are
anything if you have a dick you need to
shut the [__] up on this one seriously
this is there's the right to choose is
there unequivocal right not only do I
believe they have the right to choose I
believe that they should have to consult
anybody except for a physician about how
they exercise that right gentlemen that
is fair and ladies to be fair to us I
also believe if you decide to have the
baby a man should not have to pay
that's fair if you can kill this
[__] I can at least abandon them
it's my money my choice
[Applause]
and if I'm wrong then perhaps we're
wrong people that are here to political
correctness are in my opinion [__]
[__] I can see some of you sitting in
judgment thinking are [__] [__]
that is an offensive phrase but it's not
that offensive a phrase not when you
compare it to my impersonation of a
[__] [__] that's offensive
compared to that phrase doesn't seem as
bad now and is it I was trying to segue
in the kid [__] but same way it's fun
let's just jump right in shall we
internet predators yeah they're very
popular all over the television they I
can catch a predator MySpace yeah oh
[__] yeah yeah like I don't know cuz I I
was a kid at one point I don't remember
but it is pictures but uh I remember we
didn't have the internet but to avoid
predators
our parents would go up hey son
don't talk to strangers some of them
might try to [__] you you all thanks
thanks thanks for the heads up and then
you just went about your day and does
that not work for the internet now you
don't have to parent anymore oh the
Internet like they have some crazy way
of getting around that don't talk to
strangers if your parents and you're in
here I know you don't want to hear this
you'll argue at me and you'll say that
I'm twisting the back I'm wrong but this
is the truth that that probably a huge
probability when I say probably
astronomical odds
Vegas odds statistical probability
probably nobody wants to [__] your kid I
know you don't want to hear it
you want to think that child is so ultra
[__] that all the pedophiles are
there jockeying for position right now
down at the seesaws waiting for them to
come on at first period wait for it
junkie kid the O'Neill kid that's all
we're all here if you wanted your kid to
get [__] just to prove to your
neighbors in your gated community that
your kids hotter than their kid and you
say your kid out as bait and you put him
in a Catholic schoolgirl skirt with no
underpants and you made him hop on a
pogo stick to school so so his little
pink quarters shown so temptingly
towards traffic he would still probably
graduate school having never been booed
and then what an [__] you'd look like
trying to brag around a gated community
at the next cocktail mixer just by the
grace of God that no no one ever [__]
him it's only because of my hyper
vigilance and the work of my congressman
getting more laws passed on the internet
that he never got fought if I were a
parent I would prefer that pedophiles be
on the internet there's no more
pedophiles in the world than there ever
have been that like the Internet is
creating pedophiles where there were
none if I were a parent if you exist
anyway stay on the internet stay jacking
off in your basement in South Carolina
as opposed to the old-fashioned way
where they actually went down to your
schoolyard they did laughs around the
playground
Smarties on a fishing line trying to fly
fish
Jr into the Oldsmobile internet right
just don't [__] the kid that's all you
should worry about but that's now a
video forgetting the Attorney General he
says his number one focus is to stop the
kid [__] but he doesn't he wants to
go after the Internet
he's not going after the guy with the
kid in the camera he just was that they
used that fear-mongering to get more
government control in your life more
legislation more oh no I don't want to
have to be responsible for my own kid
you take care of it mr. government and
if I get tired of it I'll just vote for
the other party that'll make a
difference so I'll tell you why I'm late
one late joining I think I can explain
myself to you now he's a wee boy my
granddad used to take me up into the
loft I take there in a chest
they hide up there he don't knock the
chest do you know wasn't it a mere maid
and he'd have me strip me kid is a wee
boy and make love to that mare me than
the floor well he watched for his sexual
gratification
now usually uh when the old bastard was
dead I went back up in the loft I took
down the chest
domed up do you know what I found in
there a dead monkey with its legs soon
together
you didn't mind me of that monkey Johnny
why do we in this country why do we
allow so many of our innocent kids to be
shot to death why do we allow that as a
country you know why don't well not us
God why does God we have no control over
the situation at all it's all in God's
hands why does God allow so many of our
innocent kids to be shot to death and
you know they do I mean I know he has
mysterious ways y'all but who did it
what is he thinking what are you
thinking God taking on I'm not
questioning you cuz I know you have your
mysterious ways you are I'm nipping in
no no all wise but it just seems like
you're taking an awful you what is the
thinking behind it I just
[Music]
it's something that a lot of people ask
you know why is God allowing so many of
our innocent kids to be shot to death
and I have a possible answer and you're
not going to like it
but maybe maybe maybe God is allowing so
many of our kids to be shot to death so
that they can go to heaven where they
then service the ISIS terrorists and
suicide bombers as part of the
seventy-two virgins are rewarded with
[Applause]
you know you have your bad thoughts
hopefully you oppa do good fittings
everybody has a competition in their
brain of good thoughts and bad thoughts
hopefully they way the good thoughts win
for me I always have both I have like
the thing I believe the good thing
that's the thing I believe and then
there's this thing and I don't believe
it but it is there it's always this
thing and then this thing it's become a
category in my brain that I call of
course but maybe I'll give you an
example okay like of course of course
children who have nut allergies need to
be protected
of course we desegregate their food from
nuts have their medication available at
all times and anybody who manufactures
or serves food needs to be aware of
deadly nut allergies of course but maybe
maybe if touching and nut kills you
you're supposed to die
of course not of course not
of course not Jesus I have a nephew who
has that I'd be devastated if something
happening but maybe if we all just do
this for one year were done with nut
allergies forever not of course if
you're fighting for your country and you
get shot or hurt it's a terrible tragedy
of course but maybe maybe if you pick up
a gun and go to another country and you
get shot it's not that weird maybe if
you get shot by the dude you were just
shooting at it's a tiny bit your fault
[Applause]
of course of course slavery is the worst
thing that ever happened listen listen
you all clapped for dead kids with the
nuts for kids dying from from nuts you
applauded so you're in this with me
ma'am you understand you don't get to
cherry-pick those kids did nothing to
you of course of course slavery is the
worst thing that ever happened of course
it is every time it's happened
black people in America Jews in Egypt
every time the whole race of people has
been enslaved it's a terrible terrible
thing of course but maybe maybe every
incredible human achievement in history
was done with slaves every single thing
where you go how did they build those
pyramids they just threw human death and
suffering at them until they were
finished how did we traverse the nation
with a railroad so quickly we just threw
Chinese people in caves and blew them up
and didn't give a [__] what happened to
them there's no end to what you can do
when you don't get a [__] about
particular people you can do anything
that's where human greatness comes from
is that we're shitty people that we [__]
others over even today how do we have
this amazing micro technology because
the factory were there making these they
jump off the [__] roof because it's a
nightmare in there you really have a
choice you can have candles and horses
and be a little kinder to each other or
let someone suffer in measurably far
away just so you can leave a mean
comment on YouTube while you're taking a
[__] I was on a train in a train stop it
was during like rush hour and and no one
knew why the train stopped - the
conductor said folks it may be a
half-hour delay in service a woman just
was struck and killed by the train and
everybody went why don't you just be
honest and do what you want to do and go
oh my god this dead [__] is holding
[Applause]
didn't you know why people jaegerman do
you know why you don't have transsexual
you don't know why no I don't know maybe
the abnormal gene would be hetero that's
true
hey maybe the normal gene would be those
ladies that normal to be gay but cut
their [__] into vaginas no if you're
looking to make it in standard
television you're not gonna go on the
right route you're not sending this tape
to CVS
I'm sick of Obama's wife yeah this isn't
some Republican rant either it's just
kind of first ladies in general you know
I don't know what it is all throughout
my life with each presidency like these
first ladies they've just gotten more
and more like like like chatty you know
more more chiming in like leaning into
the frame spitting out their ideas it's
just like what why are you talking right
you weren't elected shut up your
husband's not running a lemonade stand
here he's running the country
you know just chime in let me guess is
this considered sexist it is why well
okay you're just not a dead leg let me
ask you this all right let's say you had
a leak in your house okay you call a
plumber up he shows up
and he goes yeah I think the leaks
coming from the upstairs bathroom we
need to shut it off the but then all of
a sudden his wife walks in who isn't a
plumber
[Applause]
take his Caravan tack what should we
like with all due respect shut the [__]
up I need a plumber in this moment I
like sending olive branch here alright
at some point there's gonna be the first
female president right exactly
which means at that moment you're gonna
have the first male first lady right and
when that happens that too needs to shut
his trap I don't want to hear a word out
of them I want to hear from the
president you sir go do some first lady
stuff all right go get yourself some
gloves fit go up to your elbows smile
and nod during speeches go put your own
Flair redecorate in the White House
right which leads you to Michelle Obama
right now she's sitting there holding up
those hashtags from that hashtag
bringbackourgirls remember that it's
like I blew my mind it's like why are
you showing me that I'm a stand-up
comedian like what am I gonna do to get
those curls back why don't you look
across the dinner table it's like you
see that guy that it's the leader of the
free world tell him to pick up the phone
balsam Navy SEALs insolvent what what am
I gonna do show up with a sharpened mic
standard show
one thing that always makes me happy
always makes me smile I love it when old
married couples dive really close
together I love it
I will clip that out of a newspaper
every time I see it to me there was just
nothing more romantic than a good
old-fashioned murder-suicide
murder-suicide always makes me happy
murder-suicide to the best it's the best
kind of suicide by far we can all agree
on that little sister doctor assisted
suicide
get that weak suicide no collagen
supports I'm all about murder-suicide
we're juicing was heads great think
about murder-suicide like this do you
hear your friend chef committed suicide
your only thought is just devastation oh
my god what could I have done to save my
friend job you hear friend Jeff killed
his wife and then himself
you just think yuck doesn't [__] around
I should have shown Jeff more respect
back in the deck
I got me some boss he wasn't cleaning
that [__] up
a murder-suicide murder-suicide is
practically a victimless crime
you are allowed the Kilson you are
allowed to kill somebody as long as you
just kill yourself immediately then it's
even Steve you're still skeptical think
about it like this if you're walking
down the street somebody walks up and
punches you in the face you were gonna
press charges and no doubt if somebody
walks up to you on the street punches
you in the face
takes a step back and then punches
themself in the face have a good day you
don't even tell your friends about
murder suicide is a victimless crime as
long as you don't leave behind any kids
got to kill them too